[موسيقى]
قد تغدو هذه الصرخه حلما يراود اليابانيين
اصوات تنخفض تدريجيا في الدوله الحاديه
عشره من حيث عدد السكان بحسب احصاءات ورد
ميترز
يتكاثر الوجود البشري بهم وبازديادهم اما
يصبحون عبئا او يدا تشد على زمام العجله
الاقتصاديه وفعلا هذا ما يؤرق اليابان ذلك
البلد الذي يقدر عدد سكانه باكثر من 126
مليون نسمه ويمثل واحدا فاصل 62% من
اجمالي عدد سكان العالم يشكو قله في عدد
المواليد
تداعيات كورونا ونقصان الزيجات سببان
اساسيان لانخفاض عدد المواليد بنسبه خمسه
في المئه اي الى نحو
770,000 في العام الماضي وذلك مع تسجيلها
اكثر من 47 الف حاله وفاه اثر الجائحه
عدد المواليد في اليابان بسرعه منذ بدايه
العقد الاول من القرن الحادي والعشرين اذا
استمرنا في هذا الاتجاه
فسينخفض عدد الشباب بسرعه في العقد الثالث
من هذا القرن بضعف المعدل الحالي
تراجع منذ 17 عاما هو سابع انخفاض على
التوالي يشيب ازمه ديموغرافيه تقترب مع
توتر الاوضاع ومن المتوقع ان ينخفض من نحو
126 مليون الى 87 مليون نسمه بحلول عام
2070 اذا لم تتخذ الحكومه ما يكفي من
تدابير جذريه لمعالجه الانكماش السريع
والشيخوخه السكانيه اسراء الصغير العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات